هم خطوا المواجهه الاول في وجهي اي طارئ
صحي في لبنان وقد ان الاوان ليتحسن ضد
الكوليرا فالعاملون في مستشفى رفيق
الحريري الحكومي ياخذون معركه مواجهه
البكتيريا
فالكوليرا التي عادت الى البلاد بعد عقود
من احتوائها دفعت وزاره الصحه لاطلاق حمله
تلقيح واسعه النطاق في المرحله
الاكثر خطوره للتعرض للوباء نحن خلال 10
ايام راح يوصلنا 900 الف بسرعه ورح نبدا
بالمرحله الثانيه بما تبقى من مناطق
انهك المرض مصطفى فالطفل الذي لم يتجاوز
الرابعه بدات رحله علاجه للتوب ومع تدفق
الحالات المشتبه فيها الى هذا المستشفى في
محافظه عكار تواجه المستشفيات الميدانيه
التي انشات بشكل استثنائي تحديات جما عن
مكان المتطوعين الاطباء من التحديات يعني
كنا عاطينهم كيف بدنا نكفي ونستمر عندنا
اعداد يعني عندك 30 متطوع حاليا بالمستشفى
بالاضافه للاطباء
يهزئون من وضع فاق قدرتهم على الاحتمال
فكل مقومات الحياه مفقوده هنا فلاجئون
السوريون يؤكدون ان الاصابات بالكوليرا
تنتشر في صفوفهم نتيجه التلوث وغياب البنا
التحتيه عن مخيمتهم
وعلى طول الاولاد على طول عم يلعبوا هون
يعني لا تقتصر تجليات الازمه هنا على مياه
الصرف الصحي بل تصل الى مياه الشرب
والماكل ويعاني عدد كبير من سكان المخيم
عوارض الكوليرا دون ان تجرى لهم فحوص
مخبريه كحالي اطفال خديجه عم نشرب من ميه
البير يعني هي عند كل المخيم تقريبا عم
يشرب منها بخوف كثير يعني هلا اولادي
ثلاثه كلهم عم يعانوا من الاسهال ما فيني
همم توجه لاي مركز لانه اكيد التكاليف رح
تكون كبيره وانا ما فيني عليها وعلى الرغم
من تعويم السلطات على قرب احتواء الكوليرا
يبقى المسار طويلا وشرقا فالمعضله لا تكمن
في القضاء على الوباء وحسب بل تتعداه الى
لي انعكاسات الصحيه للبنيه التحتيه
المتهلكه بعدم قدره السلطات على اصلاحها
تعود الكوليرا الى لبنان بعد ثلاثه عقود
من احتوائها وعلى الرغم من الجهود
المبذوله لمواجهتها فانها تضع نظام الصحه
والاقتصاديه امام تحديات اضافيه لبلد يشهد
انهيارا غير مسبوق على المستويات كافه
كارمن جوده الجزيره عكار شماليه لبنان